welcome to this video playing ashi barai
as the netherlands you let's see again
open the sodium for a change i play this
funky Bishop d7 line an interesting
sideline it looks so weird I know but
test some points this is one of them we
like the channel thanks okay so we now
get a position type that is very much
known from very well known from the the
night off the only difference is visa
instead of a 6 like in the night off I
now have Bishop d7 plate so it's a bit
more development but on the other hand a
6 is often a very useful um okay knight
c6 I mean
now it feels nice that you already have
the bishop 1d seven so I guess with the
corner covering d5 and allowing root be
a door Queen B 6 with direct play on the
dark squares yeah the bishop on g7 is an
enormous enormous looking piece yeah to
e5 or f6 mmm yeah I guess he five
sometimes they go to f6 in those lines
never really sure why that is probably
in the lines that all the games that
I've seen there were some concrete
reasons I believe here it looks very
nice with this play on the B file and
the diagonal combined okay I can play
Queen 85 now with some threats down
should i do that on is there something
better Queen 85 looks good though very
natural looking I'm probably yeah almost
threatening some some sacrifice on b2
combined with an idea three or something
then Bishop c3 there is some substantial
pressure here yeah but he can castle
okay um how to play now Queen going to
be form that's probably just a three and
I've need to return its problem I'm
sorry a nice position in in many ways
but not quite sure how to exactly play
it
Quincy file a night c4 maybe it could be
an ATM it was also like g6 controlling
'if 5 + f4 preventing those pawn pushes
it looks like it looks fine in a way for
black but it's not so clear how to
continue let's say King edge one night
c4 takes takes d5 this kind of moves can
prove to be difficult to meet Anna
practical game I can probably just take
what the pawn hmm they are probably I
can yeah maybe he is preparing that
night c4 takes takes five and I cannot
take d 536 so this is something to avoid
maybe just Kathleen with the rook on d1
the likelihood of f4 ever happening
after some preparation has some I gone
down considerably and of course I can
protect the whole thing with Bishop e6
also there should be six then 94 okay no
not c4 text xe5 is still a big problem
so
yeah I wonder if what about f4 is this
how bad is this do I need to play 96
preventing it on hmm night see phone
takes takes you 5 is still possible but
wait wait wait 'if I've d5 e6 Bishop
takes this is a fantastic compensation
for the exchange okay well this is this
I'm not afraid of maybe a form
maybe takes on dev form the e5 d5 d6 is
not a problem at all it's so in fact
very nice position even f4 though maybe
F form
mmm yeah f form yeah I think this is
this is a good exchange sacrifice if he
does not play e6 then the whole thing
really didn't make much sense fr though
maybe f4 therefore I can also play G
form I do need to take now ok maybe is
preparing that what should I do push up
f5 maybe yeah activate this e 6 I can
also take with the pawn or i can move
the rock actually I don't need to
sacrifice something necessarily um oh d
for now and a 2 hangs and come on
I'm head on the clock that's really
round my little this looks like a good
control for black yeah the rook is
saying it is getting very low on time um
probably rook da am keeping the pawn and
keep beat wonder tech um g-form and yeah
keep it closed okay so taking on age 6 /
I go h5
yeah 93 is irritating me but ok I can I
can go back night g3 a queen e6 for
example ok this looks looks fairly
decent keeping the material and maybe
behind one LED three now
yeah breaking from now and look to you
one yeah everything's protected yes he's
got some solid five in San time some
sort of from disconnection this year at
the end on connection issue um yeah this
was was was a complicated position
around here I think you should probably
play F for ya if it's possible actually
I'm just thinking I can take helium I
sort of saw the idea but I wasn't really
sold on it because I am give up my
important bishop but there's also this
one by that's terrible I would win a ton
of porn cm ok 35-yard e6 is really
leading to a fantastic pollution can
check this yeah Bishop here Bishop here
the center this is fantastic white as as
no attacking what's taking chances
whatsoever and black has great position
yeah stock wishes from minus one already
a very good position so someday rotm
starting to really envy be hugely better
yeah very very difficult now to defend
maybe be three yeah computer wants to
play be three and then a three
it was just a slight edge for Blackmon
yeah this is tough to evaluate what
should try to do something something
active I think that the the problems
really start when when white was taking
on c6 probably might be three is better
I don't know I don't feel that giving
giving up the knight on d4 here and
allowing this this play on the beef is
really good it seems very comfortable
for black now okay thanks for watching